l'allocution d'emmanuel macro hier soir
a provoqué une avalanche de réactions
tout au long de la journée des critiques
notamment de l'opposition qui dénonce un
discours du chef de l'état en campagne à
cinq mois de la présidentielle sans être
candidat déclaré pour autant on en parle
tout de suite avec notre reporter neige
à des rasades devant l'elysée bonsoir
nadège alors cette allocution cévennes
et le maquereau qui embarrasse entre
autres les ténors de la droite qui
parlent de tentatives de hold up sur
leurs idées
hier j'ai entendu un candidat à la
présidence de la république est les mots
sont signés de gérard larcher président
l ère du sénat et une fois n'est pas
coutume à l'ensemble de l'opposition est
du même avis nucléaire retraite travail
à droite on accuse le président de la
république d'avoir pioché dans le
programme des républicains de l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 à valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france candidate à l'investiture
lr par le même de tentative de hold-up
est coupée
il ya eu clairement une
instrumentalisation de la crise qu vide
pour faire un discours de campagne
puisque on l'a bien vu emmanuel macron
est candidat il a fait une tentative de
hold up sur les idées de la droite le
travail le nucléaire les retraites mais
c'est une nouvelle fois vouée à l'échec
il a regardé le débat des républicains
c'est évident mais ça ne trompe personne
même son de cloche du côté du
rassemblement national marine le pen se
moque d'un président de la république je
cite qui vivent dans un monde parallèle
la troisième dose n'aura donc été qu'une
excuse pour faire un discours de
campagne dont presque toutes les
déclarations sont éminemment contestable
chômage insécurité pouvoir d'achat le
monde parallèle des manuels macron est
loin des réalités que vivent les
français et la neige à gauche on ironise
en invitant le président à rejoindre les
as l'air
absolument alors pour jean luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron s'est présenté comme un
candidat président comme un président
candidat il a d'ailleurs déploré le fait
que son temps de parole ne soit pas
décomptés comme tels jean luc mélenchon
estime qu'il ya de plus en plus de
points communs entre le président de la
république et les républicains jean luc
mélenchon qui invite le président de la
république à rejoindre tout bonnement le
parti de la droite
clairement emmanuel macron est candidat
et son temps de parole n'est pas
décompté comme tel il mélange les genres
d'une manière anormale il agit comme
candidat président emmanuel macron parle
d'angoise et dit qu'il faut avoir
confiance en nous mêmes mais c'est lui
qui accroît les angoisses en s'en
prenant aux droits des chômeurs et en
disant qu'il va falloir travailler plus
longtemps les républicains peuvent
arrêter leur congrès ils ont déjà leur
candidat
sans surprise au sein de la majorité
présidentielle ont fait bloc derrière le
président de la république et gabriel
attal a défendu le président de la
république il a répondu aux critiques
après cette neuvième allocution
télévisée d'emmanuel macron depuis le
début de la pandémie le porte parole du
gouvernement a estimé qu'il était normal
que le président elle s'exprime sur tous
les sujets qui sont au coeur de la vie
et des inquiétudes des français qui plus
est dans un contexte de crise historique
fin de citation merci beaucoup et nadège
abderrazak